I'm here to talk to you about the Scots
language know the language I grew up
talking and so I'm going to start
talking to you after my first day at
school so for the first day at school
the very first lesson at the school
William was he can eat or crate can eat
or gray said we went and the whole SWAT
only holds the Minton's wanna mittens
the words was new words other names of
the animals were trying dogs Wesley dogs
it was Niels and Stuckey's was nice
takis crows bleeps cuz those ferrets odd
us was wrong and for that it wasn't it
to start my house was near whose order
him main body my Aram's one the Aram's
my horns only horns my fingers was near
my fingers my fat wasn't him I thought
my hair wasn't in my head my head was in
my head when it came here what you'd
done in life
you could name wipe a button you could
name three powerful war and the buttons
of the bike he couldn't eat jerk through
a whole night you couldn't eat junk away
you couldn't even have a glass of water
so I was at the school and were we were
get an old tub are cotton for str8 then
all these new exotic watts
we were lament like foot hand head stop
the minute a bucket and know sometimes
some of your Watsu garden you get what's
like cat has that low done yes cats cats
fame and then you to what but bottom and
they say well sometimes but that small
grabber that goes I'd say the skill
that's called the stream but Mason the
time you pick it horn up near build up
mass mass how to spell it and it is no
act as an award it's
eat or have eaten right so I'm know here
a gun angry about what happened to me as
lesson was begin Liam B wins all your
Scotland same day tens of thousands of
wins or your Scotland and millions our
folk a forest or tell you can eat or
gray said hasta Canada English a cacti
are the gears aren't analyzed now heat
up a curtain and pero my good English
words and went through education he
better better him I stole used all these
words with my family my friends my
neighbors and he always gonna one-up
Western fella what was the name of these
what's on the eyelids these watch Akane
use right so a for a came up the end
Vaness the day at end of your work I
gave back my opinion hundreds of times
by thorkell of tag one of these week
eight books than hey Allah Cara right so
it was a tour of Scotland 1677 they are
fella called Palmas [ __ ] fear York Shia
and and I spoke it mentions and unless
he's on his way your Denis and it just
mentions that this is an anvil nests in
the surrounding areas
and most of the highlands people speak a
sort of wild Irish but some of the
better sort speak Scottish right it's
not good to have what really a slugging
everybody's it was a bit but you know
like that Scottish
that is the what that used to be used
for all these what I can t use that what
tale through education no you can you
see that and so and the Scottish is
called Scott right and afford eighteenth
century or Scotland no wounds and even
in Inverness folk spoke Scots and you're
quite happy that's why they talk scores
all my water right grant go Andrea and
if you look at the old borrow records
for Inverness which then was called an
ominous no and Vaness you'll fun all
these words now is
Tipene Amitabha cotton Newfoundland heat
horn fat cow scab and your fun Galvan
market console and Kirk are these words
that your Nellie though I know said what
happened what happened to my scotland
see all these words are trying all these
words that are just no right well if
you're a posh me how its display complex
but feel like mush me I'd say Adams math
for further economics right so [ __ ]
Maine time for our foundations that the
boat fin de economics and Glasgow and
Edinburgh and but what he was and real
wife was he was a professor a rhetoric
and and what what you done at the end
his life is it to his palms it's even
indeed tack oh my - grab something on
the fire a pair farewell Phoenicians and
artilleries on moral sentiment right so
all his books or the walk everything he
talk at falling a fire but it's miss
popular book whilst it was alive one of
them anyway it was as seventeen forty
lectures and rhetoric and bell letters
and we stole the copies and acts of
support law and if you look at that your
fun he's teaching folk he talk properly
and inventions it doesn't invention
score a bit what he says is this is the
language spoken in the war countries of
Scotland as no and has been for hundreds
of years nothing but a dialect of
anguish right now it doesn't send that I
get the young life sentence than her but
if you think he was actually currently
folk or thought they spoke last language
called Scots neo top sports so it's gone
bit affronted us but like we don't talk
area language right and later on the
book it says the same for the garlic
this is Irish Welsh in the air that's a
the garlic are nothing but die
elect of the same language right so I
certainly nice lectures this is the most
intellectual guy in Scotland and as he
seen at the time the way wakes her bathe
other languages Scotland garlic and
scores so response to us Fisk Oakland
was em Edinburgh Glasgow Aberdeen what
they done was the earth right and to go
through elocution lessons with 300 years
a elocution in Scotland or trying to get
folk to talk ray em so what they've done
at first was they tried the Amity the
language of the South England so had
they been successful I would perhaps be
speaking to you something like this but
what we know nerve psychology
neuroscience as your first accent the
accent you get when you're born is
prefixed and it's awfully hard to change
that accent
the villains you make the coincidence
you make so what they don't f Double R
after about 10 years are tryna was eight
in Scots language before me all the
words that that knee came to match up
with a language of the South England and
then the ones that what to hit left they
swapped a bit olive oil sands in the
countenance and they put a new
consonants so horn you change that the
hand and then you put a DNN honda right
so they changed last week and the last
we but that was left and the language
and the coda a comment mainly Edinburgh
the Athens of the north they called that
attic I was a name for this language it
was like anguish we are Scottish accent
and and then the court or the other
Scots wine which is Doric right which
meant its eighth Athens so did he stay
here they were the one they shaft they
weren't right knee boiler that's what we
talk Doric we talked with auric and it
doesn't change the way they spoke but
through the rest of Scotland all the way
the borders what they'd done was that
thus Doric winter fashion and it changed
the corrupt language bad language
bastardization and all these words are
used to educate folk and how he talked
write em the day he asked um speak folk
talk about on glass goddess come speak
like was on so that is all scott as our
language it was a language and that's
artic it's a constructed language but no
that's been generations and generations
our folk talk now so that's just as much
a languages course and garlic now ah -
was done a third a single scale for a
foundation on science right now it was
was men have begun on and our 18th
century timers when it be evidence of
his science but the doesn't offender in
science so what I'm going to do is tell
you back with the neuroscience of what's
going on we're language right so I'll
tell you why image yellow carrots uh
behavior something goes on the brain so
tell you about the first time that are
held a human brain right so years and
years and years of study I knew all the
parts of the brain are seen at certain
air I could see or there's a central
sulcus at sir frontal walks temporal
warps could see the pawns a cerebellum
great and I've attained animal horns and
help me I realized that thus was a woman
thus but atashi tin the decision
Sylvia's board a science so that we
could look at her and learn Meribah the
brain and try and prevent the gener of
brain diseases
thus patashu in ma horn with all the
memories and other life experience a
nice woman's lifetime and Anna with
every single what that she can so what'd
he say hard something like Alex yet
named asam did by chocolate
John Wayne right what we tartan would be
the temporal whoop-ass can i area here
with hiked fee but be some facial
recognition about a visual stuff well
she recalls or join me in looks like
lake but if you but i say other naming
outdoor or I seem hungry Tom but the
foam of the brain would get regulator or
the areas today we have the muscles work
with mind on what she felt like when she
packed her up with a call every need
arias mail or sense of smell she would
main [ __ ] smell like she'd main which
he tasted like when she cast on all that
comes on the fall brain comes on the
activation and that's her what's and
language work in the brain they tagged
all these different bats in the brain
and they start going to work right so a
few but they say to me somewhat sleigh
drill my auditory cortex and ma visual
areas would come on em I've never used a
slide rule if you sit in a landing here
and has brain or the bats today we're
moving fingers the parts today be moths
which command might be some phone memory
as for slide rule would come and so put
this as mean for a skies right so if you
are a safe us to say me something like
the dog right well what would happen in
my brain would be maybe the same stuff
auditory cortex come in and be a visual
maybe but the dog feels like if you
gotta say me the dog what we tartan
would be all the memories or all the
dogs that have had and all the dogs are
can heard my lifetime more Stara Duke
fury we blue
mosey all these dogs of Kendrick command
and the purpose of my brain they want
David cause they're gonna in my scan
smellier the tastier and I like Jeff II
saw that kinda stuff boy like it's Rick
Ritter
right so that's the difference between
dog and dog and and marbling you've got
all these what thousands and thousands
and thousands are what the army I would
m3 doer spray : a goes on and on and on
a cannula slowly or them but they are
all in my brain and Scott speakers or
your score won't have the words and not
brain and put the brain as if you're
studying language you're here it's a
bunch of singe marks and paper but on
the brain what languages as it's the way
that we can affect and read one
another's mains
it's the tools that we have for were
inventions and what imaginations the
tools are available for us
so when you can tell oh yeah what's a
rhyme that's what's in tiny Horner and
the bike really really eyes so that
language is there and Scotland for
everybody to use Bureau whether you talk
at your cell or no you need to be our
area if you're an artist it's there for
you if you are a poor and author an
actor you should remember however as
part of your repertoire if you're a
teacher or a doctor or a therapist or a
counselor thank about how if you want me
some day talk scores thing about how you
can bring with us and make it better
what you do if you're a designer we are
at engineer here a technologist well
chef nunya planner where everything is
going to be a bit voice recognition and
nothing is getting Bowl for the scores
language so the language Scots and
garlic faith naturally evolved with
physical emotional and intellectual rang
air one skip a Scotland that's there
it's powerful user we've got it dropped
that's eighteenth century we are looking
at what language we've got is the up
talking about language
you